atlanta is like you know the motown of
the south pizza
town atlanta georgia
[Music]
the cultural capital of the south has
been the breeding ground for some of
music's
biggest artists for years
[Music]
man we got an amazing array of talent
i got the
artists who are currently lighting up
the world stage
and legends who will forever be
solidified in music history
from ray charles to childish gambino
and gladys knight to sierra
[Music]
atlanta is a big part of what's made me
who i am today
atlanta's contribution to the american
music industry
is undeniable
[Music]
man that's where it all started for me
with way too many names to list
you can't help but wonder how did the
heart of the peach state become
such a rich hub for african-american
talent
i don't know what it is about atlanta we
just dope is it the location
we sit at the forefront of influence the
history
there's something in the waters they
would say or similar to what sierra said
does atlanta just have the juice what
kicks off atlanta's uh rise in terms of
black expressive culture
according to maurice hopson it's a
combination of factors
but there is one person in particular
who played a pivotal role in
establishing atlanta
as the black music mecca it is today and
he wasn't even a musician
never shall i let you down
maynard jackson was elected as the first
black mayor one of the things he does is
in 1974
he builds the bureau of cultural affairs
believing that all great cities have
great art
mayor jackson had a vision for atlanta
he worked alongside then governor and
future president
jimmy carter to implement initiatives
that would boom the art and
entertainment industry in the city
governor jimmy carter along with maynard
jackson
are able to create the georgia uh film
music and digital entertainment office
which presented attacks
and as a result of that atlanta it sets
the stage for
tax incentives for expressive art to be
produced and because atlanta at the time
was a black city
atlanta focused on black art and culture
[Music]
yep that's 10 things i hate about you
and the song in the background is
atlanta's sos bands hit song
just be good to me
[Music]
[Applause]
the late 70s and early 80s ushered in
the funk era for the city
at the time atlanta was the underdog in
music compared to new york or la
so it became a place for artists to
[Music]
experiment
the sos band that is the atlanta sound
[Music]
the sos band was responsible for
creating a sound
that eventually laid the foundation for
atlanta's take on
r b
[Music]
and later the city's groundbreaking
hip-hop scene
when i think back on it now pretty
incredible it's pretty incredible
musicians la reid and kenneth babyface
edmonds
left los angeles to launch a new record
label in atlanta in the late 80s
and set the scene for the 90s
a decade that put atlanta on the map as
a place where talent
can thrive atlanta's kind of rise as a
as a black cultural city has a lot to do
with a lot of his transplants that come
here too so it's not
just local atlanta talent i think it's a
real convergence on the
black america and the black world coming
into the city
with help from music exec clive davis la
reid and babyface created lafay's
records
it was like we all had a dream of making
it and it seemed real
when l.a reading babyface moved to
atlanta because it's like okay well
if they sign them and they got their
record on the radio all we need is
somebody to hear us and we're gonna blow
up
that's how we looked at it we're on the
making of our video
waterfalls it's our new video coming out
our third one
[Music]
the first two major groups left they
signed were tlc
and crisscross
[Music]
both groups went platinum quick and soon
the 90s saw a string of new artists
based out of the a
but none quite as unique as this dynamic
duo
outcasts formed in 1992 made up of andre
3000 and big boy
the two became known for their mix of
funk and rap
creating their own lane when we got into
it we were high school kids and we just
like
we just want to do something fun and and
different and push it
and if it's not that why do it i'm
talking about a black man in heaven here
their debut album southern playalistic
cadillac music
brought the style of southern rap to
atlanta
then the world with outcasts they gave
you a rundown
of the city of atlanta outside of those
kind of like rosy ideas about
atlanta being the home of dr king and
one of the birthplaces of the civil
rights movement they were like nah this
is what's happening in atlanta
after the civil rights movement let me
tell you about how folks want to talk
about a champion ideas of education but
what happens if education doesn't work
how do we talk about working class
communities how do we get by how do we
survive how do we complicate these
narratives that are in place and also
how do we show you that you know atlanta
is popping as a city you know what i'm
saying like ultimately
it was the introduction to the potential
of the south having a hip-hop city
the platinum success of their debut
project lets outcast winning best new
rap
group at the 1995 source awards beating
out nwa at the height of the east coast
west coast rivalry
while accepting their win the duo got
booed
but andre 3000 left the audience with
these
memorable words but it's like this
though i'm tired of folks you're saying
[Applause]
closed minded folks what i'm saying it's
like we got a demo tape don't everybody
want to hear but it's like this
i've got something to say that's all i
got to say did the south got something
to say that's all i got to say
that infamous line opened a door for
other southern artists
to not just be heard but respected
[Applause]
as time went on outcast continued to
have something to say
and the fans wanted to hear more the
group
continued to top the charts and took
home some grammys in the process
atlanta was a city that had to be
included in
any conversation in big cities that we
could have
that was one of the barriers that i
broke another trendsetter straight out
of atlanta is super producer jermaine
dupri
lafays and rowdy records set the
foundation for
tons of hip-hop and r b record labels to
be based in atlanta
which plays a huge factor in attracting
new artists
there's a lot of dope producers and
songwriters that live in atlanta
and have been kind of like the backbone
i guess in pushing the culture dupree
founded so-so deaf records in the
mid-1990s
signing acts like bow wow the brat
jagged edge
and escape
[Music]
the priest specifically changed the game
with the ladies of escape
aka candy burris tamika tiny collins and
sisters latosha scott and tamika scott
by using this one technique he was
actually the person that introduced us
to that world
and was like you know what i'm gonna do
i'm gonna put your voices
on these hip-hop here tracks
on the right thing to decide
we can't take all the credit for that i
have to say you know thanks to jermaine
for just kind of
rolling that out for us to say hey this
is something new that i think that you
guys should be a part of
so he created that sound for us and i
think people have emulated that
[Music]
singing over hip-hop tracks is now the
industry standard
everyone from beyonce
[Music]
to ariana grande and atlanta native
summer walker do it
in the early 2000s atlanta's very own
ludicrous
took his dirty south sound mainstream
with his label disturbing the peace
and back-to-back hits
so when i wrote that song i honestly
could not say to myself that you know 10
20 years down the line that people will
still be singing it but that's just a
testament to
in my opinion what music is all about
and that's making timeless songs
and not just trendy songs
[Music]
speaking of trends in the early 2000s
before the tick tock challenges rappers
out of atlanta they had us getting down
with the choreography
i'm doing the poor palace you know you
know there's a period of time where a
lot of the hip-hop coming out of atlanta
is really promoting dance i mean lean
with it rock with it and snap your
fingers
[Music]
little john and the east side boys hit
the scene hard with crunk music
this is when the dance crazes exploded
with artists like defoel and their song
laffy taffy
and dj unks walk it out
[Applause]
during the early 2000s we also started
to see the emergence of trap music
this is right when i'm coming into my
full tism
you know what i'm saying t.i released
his debut album
aptly named trap music with a z under
his record label grand hustle
now almost two decades later it's the
main sound coming out of the city
migos future and gucci mane are just a
few of the names who are currently
dominating the music scene
with trap sound and while it's
celebrated by many
some have a cause for concern no
disrespect to
artists that are that have participated
in trap but we have to have a serious
conversation around what it means to be
in the trap
we're talking about the militarization
of the police we're talking about the
school to prison pipelines
selling of crack cocaine in black
communities the city of atlanta is now
glorifying this whole trap culture
but they don't really want to deal with
the repercussions of what crack cocaine
did to black communities
it's a beautiful city uh but just like
in any other place it's had its problems
and
we have to understand that those that
are creating the music that those that
are producing the culture
they have to be able to kind of
articulate what the people on the ground
in the city are experiencing
recently trap music has expanded beyond
the borders of atlanta
and it has become one of the most stream
genres
across the entire us it's even made its
way overseas
with k-pop artists getting in on the
game
the influence can also be heard in the
latin market
recently i asked offset from migos about
his take on the genre and where he sees
it headed in the future
it's already number one so i think it's
just stay there it's relatable it feels
it's it's a lot of people going through
that going through struggle going
through pain you know i'm saying going
through harder times
trying to make it out of one situation
to be in a better situation so i think
that you gotta
it's gonna stay ahead whether it's trap
crunk music r b funk or whatever is next
it's clear that atlanta artists have
left their industry defining marks on
the music scene
while it's hard to pin down or describe
everything that makes atlanta
such a rich hub for african-american
talent one thing we know for sure
is that whatever it is
atlanta has it all the incredible
artists that have come out of there all
the great culture that's come out of
atlanta
you know though we all go on to do
bigger things you know it all
is about to start you know
you